To become psychologically flexible
is more than just
addressing personality.
It's actually addressing the way
we really relate to ourselves.
Flexibility is the ability to adjust
your thoughts, actions and feelings
to the circumstances
you find yourself in.
Situations change,
and so it's important to be able
to adjust and behave in the most
functional way to achieve your goals.
When you're born,
your brain is not finished.
Infant brains are born
under construction.
They're waiting for a set
of wiring instructions
from the world.
If you expose your children
to a lot of varying experiences
then you're basically wiring
your child's brain
to function in a flexible way
and to learn new things
when necessary.
If your child's experiences
are very restricted
then your child will have less
flexibility to adjust their actions
to the situations that they're in.
There's a really well-known
demonstration of flexibility
called the Stroop test.
A sequence of words,
such as red, green, yellow, blue
but written in different colours.
When you present people
with a whole list of these
you find that it takes people longer
to name the colour of the ink
when the word is written in a colour
that is different to the actual word.
The idea behind that
is in order to be able
to name the colour
requires people
to switch between
different pieces of information
in their mind.
In simple terms,
what happens is that
when they scan the word colour
the automatic processes
of reading the word
interfere with the person's ability
to state the colour out loud.
The more difficult
people find this generally
the less cognitively flexible
they are.
When your brain
can't predict something,
or when you have to take in new
information that you didn't predict,
that's what we call learning.
So your brain can update,
it can learn,
or your brain can ignore
the sense data
and just go with its own prediction.
Flexibility means tailoring
a response to the specific situation,
either by predicting well
or by learning when
there is prediction error.
A lot of what psychological
flexibility is about
is the way in which people use
resources that they have available
in dealing with stress.
One of the things about
psychological inflexibility
is that people are not
using their resources
in a way that's helpful to them.
Quite often they're using a very
narrow range of their resources
to be able to adapt.
And the idea
in psychological flexibility
is really to move people
from a state of what psychologists
call languishing,
of being stuck in a less than
satisfactory situation,
to move them out of that zone
into a zone of achieving
more of their potential.
What stops people
from changing their lives
from a state of low satisfaction
to one of higher satisfaction
is quite often to do
with inflexibility
in the way they approach
the problem that they're facing.
So there's a really deep lesson here.
You can take more control
over your environment.
You are not just a passive recipient
of whatever the world gives you.
Spending time cultivating experiences
and foraging for new information
is an investment in maintaining
a flexible brain.
These are all opportunities to expose
yourself to prediction error
so that your brain can solve problems
more flexibly in the future.
So exposing yourself
to stuff you don't know,
and maybe even ideas you don't like,
might make you feel crappy
in the moment
but actually
it is a really good investment.